You know what sounds really good after a long day?
Some wings. I don't wash my chicken because you genuinely don't have to,
but you can do as you please.
This is what I make when I want a quick dinner.
I started by seasoning my wings,
adding some baking powder to my seasoning,
and then popping them on a wire rack.
While those were baking for about an hour,
I started on my chimichurri.
They were making chimichurri wings.
I've been thinking about this combination for about a week now,
so finally I'm coming around to recipe testing it.
I chopped up some parsley,
cilantro, shallot,
some capers, grated some garlic,
some chili, and then seasoned my chimichurri.
Made sure to give it a really good mix.
I also added some Korean red pepper flakes to it.
After about 30 minutes, I flip my wings and pop them back in the oven.
I always like making some type of slaw to go alongside my wings.
Something creamy but not too heavy.
We shredded some cabbage carrots.
I added my tangy dressing on top
and set that aside
and got started mixing my wings with the chimichurri.
Once all my wings were coated,
I topped it with a light layer of Parmesan cheese
and these were absolutely divine.